un petit objet de 2 mm pour un grand
message de paix c'est un anneau livre le
discours numérisé du pape François
enregistré sur la place Saint-Pierre en
pleine crise du covid embarquer dans ce
petit satellite il devrait décoller
demain de Californie à bord d'une fusée
spécifique le Nano livre sera mis en
orbite à 525 km de la Terre le
Royaume-Uni la chaleur et ses
conséquences sur les gardes royaux alors
que Londres flirte avec les 30 degrés ce
joueur de trombone regardez cet évanoui
durant la répétition image en
pressionnante répétition d'une parade
qui doit se tenir samedi prochain et
puis il n'est pas le seul un autre gare
d'étanchéité sur un brancard il faut
dire que sous le bonnet noir en poils
d'ours il peut faire rapidement très
chaud depuis le début de la conquête
spatiale l'homme a envoyé une multitude
d'objets dans l'espace certains
insolites de balles de golf sur la lune
une œuvre d'art en orbite autour de Mars
un sabre laser de la saga Star Wars
plus symbolique descendre comme celle de
James Dohan acteur de Star Trek à la
base d'où il vient notre oxygène c'était
des petites bactéries quand la terre
n'avait pas d'oxygène qui mangeait le
carbone et qui faisait des prouts
d'oxygène
on a oublié c'était il y a très
longtemps on a oublié on respire du
prouts
non loin de Sydney qui a installé vous
allez le voir une crotte géante sur la
plage pour sensibiliser sur la pollution
des océans
il existe même des entreprises qui
envoient des objets à bord des fusées
pour les revendre ensuite sur Terre une
activité légale il suffit d'avoir
l'autorisation d'un état
la règle de base c'est que l'espace est
libre pour l'utilisation et
l'exploration par les États est-ce qu'on
irait pas ce scaliner un arbre
[Musique]
ça fait du bien un petit bisou merci
arbre à bientôt pouvons-nous continuer à
boire l'eau sans risque
donc aujourd'hui on connaît pas tous les
métabolites présents dans notre eau non
mais pour vous c'est pas grave
on a aucun risque pour notre santé
un silence loin d'être rassurant ce
matin un lapin a tué un chasseur c'était
d'ailleurs un lapin qui est
en fusil tout à fait merci pour la
précision c'est effectivement ce qu'on
me dit dans l'oreillette
[Musique]
je dois avouer que ça fait flipper
la plupart des scientifiques aujourd'hui
s'accordent à dire que les rayures des
zèbres seraient
un anti-mouche naturel non pour tester
cette idée deux chercheurs anglais Tim
carreau et Martin house de l'université
de Bristol on fait une expérience ils
ont pris un certain nombre de chevaux
ils en ont déguisé certains en zèbre
puis ils ont observé la façon dont les
temps se comportaient
la chanteuse Taylor Swift avait une
mouche en plein concert
Taylor Swift a poursuivi son concert
sans problème rassurez-vous
quant à la mouche
les temps ce sont des sortes de grosses
mouches qui piquent résultat il y avait
beaucoup moins de temps qui parvenait à
se poser sur les chevaux déguisés en
zèbre que sur les chevaux normaux
pourquoi et bien parce que les rayures
semblaient perturber l'atterrissage des
temps qui ne savaient plus trop où ils
étaient ils étaient trop contente qu'on
puisse enfin se lancer nous y voilà on
verra bien ce que ça va donner à vrai
dire mon regard c'est tout de suite fixé
sur son pénis et ensuite j'ai remarqué
son visage deux fois par an elle est dit
un magazine distribué dans les
associations féministes
à la une du premier numéro une main de
femme le logo du mouvement féministe
radical mégalia qui attaque les hommes
frontalement
ça représente la taille du pénis des
hommes coréens vous savez qu'on dit que
c'est la plus petite du monde
quand c'est gratuit est-ce que ce serait
pas nul produit peut-être que si et ça
se confirme avec un autre chiffre dans
cette étude 17% des hommes ont déjà
commandé de l'alcool au restaurant
uniquement pour désinhiber un petit peu
leur convives pour le reste de la soirée
Karine
ma vraie chatte
c'est le miroir de la discrimination que
nous avons subi
on a supporté ça pendant très longtemps
on a demandé aux hommes
et maintenant
tu as vu la taille de ton pénis c'est le
plus petit du monde mais si vous
m'invitez à dîner alors moi je ferai
dîner vous m'invitez à ce que vous avez
l'intention de l'utiliser comme un objet
sexuel à la fin
n'aurez pas une réponse typique donc le
premier qui m'envoie bah oui le premier
qui m'envoie une story sur mon compte
Instagram voilà avec donc
ce que vous avez deviné qui à
l'intérieur et le premier la première
j'arrive pas à m'exprimer ce matin en
fait
ce soir jumia Dawn vont faire comme de
nombreux couples non mariés en Corée
l'amour dans un lovateur
un concept importé du Japon dans les
années 80 le lovotel permet de louer une
chambre pour 15 à 30 euros de l'heure en
toute discrétion
je dirais tu vois en gel
il a sa sirène
un cambriolage
[Rires]
je vous regarde et je constate que
effectivement il y a les petits manques
quelque part
vous avez besoin de leçons monsieur
Cohen je suis heureuse que vous soyez là
pour le dire en arbitre tout à fait
neutre parce qu'on se tue quand même à
lui dire elle veut dire quoi
qu'il y a des améliorations à faire
Patrick
2 à 3 fois par mois bonjour
il change à chaque fois d'établissement
pour profiter de décor toujours
stimulant dans cet hôtel on peut par
exemple jouer au docteur ou tester son
attachement à l'autre dans une chambre
des tortures
la première fois que Patrick est séchée
sur le plateau
non sur un plan
de gourmandise contrôlée juste une
gourmandise à maîtrisée il s'agit de
cela absolument
rien d'autre on est d'accord avec Nadine
je vous laisse non je sais parce qu'il y
a des détections chez moi donc comme il
y a personne parce que je suis là je
pense qu'il faut que je me bouge je vous
embrasse je n'ai pas fait exprès je vous
le jure sur ma vie si voilà merci
de merde
[Applaudissements]